Within the Billing API, you
can integrate in-app billing
into your Android applications.
Hi.
I'm Neto Marin.
In a previous episode,
we looked at what
you can offer to users
through in-app billing.
In this episode,
let's implement it.
To make it generally
more comfortable,
we created a [INAUDIBLE]
implementation
for in-app billing version
3 API called Trivial Drive.
This app includes
convenience class
to quick setup the
in-app billing service.
You can import this
sample from Android Studio
or use a GUID to
clone repository.
But before we
actually start coding,
I will help you to set up
your app in the Google Play
Developer Console and prepare
development environment
with Android Studio.
To sell products, you need to
add them to the Google Play
Developer Console.
To add these products,
you must have an app.
But don't necessarily
publish it.
If you need help about
how to create and set up
a developer account on Google
Play, check our documentation.
To create your app, click the
Add New Application button.
Enter a name for
your new application
and click on Prepare
Store Listing.
And now you have an
Android app as a draft.
And you imagine, now it's time
to add your products, right?
Almost.
Before you can start
adding new products,
you need to upload an APK, the
Android application package,
with the billing
permission in your app.
Now, let's move to
Android Studio and check
what you need to do to prepare
the development environment,
generate and upload your APK
with in-app billing enabled.
First, you have to install
the in-app billing library
using the Android SDK Manager.
In Android Studio, we can
access it through the icon,
or using the menu, Tools,
Android, Android SDK Manager.
Then, in the SDK Manager,
go to the SDK Tools tab.
In the list of tools, check the
Google Play Billing library.
Click OK to complete
the installation.
Now you can create your project
to integrate in-app billing
or open existing
project for which you
want to use in-app billing
and start preparing it.
The communication between
Google Play and your app
will be done using a service.
And to define this
service, you need
to create an Android
Interface Definition Language
file, or AIDL.
In your project,
this file should
be placed inside a specific
directory in a package.
First, create the director AIDL
under the path Search [? Me. ?]
Then create a new package called
com.android.vending.BILLING.
A simple AIDL file,
inappbillingservice.aidl,
is provided by in-app
billing library,
and you can find it in your
SDK installation in the folder
extras/google/play_billing.
You can check during
the SDK installation
inside Android Studio.
Using the File Explorer
and Operation assistant,
copy this file
into your project.
The next step is to update
your Android manifest,
adding the permissions to
com.android.vending.BILLING
under the Application tag.
Now your approach is ready and
with the right permissions.
So you can generate APK and
upload into the Google Play
Developer Console, and
use the web interface
to add the products
and subscriptions you
want to offer.
To add your products, go to
Google Play Developer Console,
and then to the
In-app Products tab.
For example, here,
we have a product
called Gas with the ID
Gas and the price of $1.
And it's configured
as a managed product.
These IDs, also
known as SKUs, are
important because they will be
used to start the purchase flow
and make other requests.
Now that you created a product,
configured the development
environment, let's see how
to send requests and purchase
products.
Before I can start sending
requests from Google Play,
you need to establish the
connection between your app
and the in-app billing service.
The convenience class IAB
Helper provided in this sample
under the package
[INAUDIBLE] handles
the binding to the
in-app billing service.
For example, to bind your app
to the Google Play Service,
first create an IAB Helper
instance in your activities
on create method, passing
your public license key along
to the construct.
And important point here
is about your license key.
This license key can be found
in Google Play Developer Console
under the section
Services and API.
But instead of hard
coding your key,
construct it at runtime from
substrings or retrieve it from
encrypted resource before
using with the constructor.
Next, perform the service
binding by calling the start
setup method on the IAB
Helper instance you created.
To check if the
binding's finished,
implement the listener on
IAB setup finished listener.
And, if setup
completed successfully,
you can now use the
service [INAUDIBLE]
to communicate with
the Google Play.
Remember to unbind from
in-app billing service
when you are done
with your activity
because if you don't unbind,
this open service connection
could cause your device
performance to degrade.
With your connection
to Google Play working,
you can start
listing your products
and present some details.
To get the item details
from Google Play,
you can call
getSkuDetails, passing
a bundle that contains a string
[INAUDIBLE] list of product
IDs with key item ID list,
where each string is a product
ID for an item.
GetSkuDetails
returns a bundle that
contains the response code
with the key response code
and a string [INAUDIBLE] list
with the key details list.
Each string in the
[INAUDIBLE] list
is a JSON containing
the product information.
And when the user chooses a
product in your list, like Gas
in your sample, and
hits the Buy button,
it's time to start
the purchase flow.
Since all transactions
are done by Google Play,
you must create an intent
with purchase information.
This is done by calling
the method getBuyIntent,
passing the in-app building
API version, the app's package
name, the product ID to be
purchased, the purchase type,
and a developer payload string.
The developer payload
string is used
to specify any additional
argument that you
want Google Play sent back along
with the purchase information.
This method will
return a bundle,
and you can get
the pendingIntent
with the key BuyIntent.
To complete the
purchase transaction,
call the
startIntentSenderForResult
method.
Then use the pendingIntent
that you created.
In this example, we are using
an arbitrary value of 1001
for the request code.
Once the user finishes
the transaction,
you will receive the
response from Google Play
in your pendingIntent through
the method onActiveToResult.
The purchase data for the order
is a string in the JSON format
that it's mapped to the
in-app purchase data
key and the response
intent, like this one.
Anything you need you can
hit a list of purchases
that were made by your user,
calling the method getPurchase.
And Google Play
manages the local cache
for purchased
items, so you don't
need to keep your own
database or history.
Some products can be purchased
several times, like Gas
on our Trivial Drive sample.
But the in-app billing API
offers managed products,
which means that Google
Play manages and tracks
the product's ownership for you.
And before a user can purchase
the same product again,
you must send the consumption
request to Google Play.
To record a purchase
consumption,
send the consumePurchase method
to the in-app billing service
and pass in the
purchase token string
the value that identifies
a purchase to be consumed.
The purchase token is
part of the data returned
in the in-app
purchase data string
after a successful
purchase request.
Other options you
can offer in your app
is a subscription service.
Let's suppose I want my car to
go on forever without having
to worry about fuel.
Great, huh?
For a small fee,
Trivial Drive lets
me purchase a
recurring subscription
so that my tank is always full.
The purchase flow
for subscriptions
is similar to the purchase
flow for a product,
with the exception
that the product type
must be set to Subs.
Check out this video for more
details about subscriptions.
And now you know how
to prepare your project
to use in-app billing, add
the products to Google Play
Developer Console,
and also how to use
the API to list products, start
a purchase, and list purchase.
For handling funds and manging
your products programmatically,
check out docs about the
Google Play Developer API.
If you have any
questions, check out
documentation for in-app billing
on developer.android.com.
And don't forget the download
this sample application,
Trivial Drive, where you can
see all the in-app billing
implementation working.
Looking forward to
see you making money
with in-app billing.
Thanks for watching.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]